i fully agree that guys need to be the
one to pay for the date i know i was
reading some of your other stuff in
there as well i i do i uh you know
people say well what what about going
dutch what about the no no no no you you
need to establish masculine dominance
from the beginning otherwise why are you
there and the other thing is uh i don't
think enough guys plan for success
so when they're they i i answer lots and
lots of questions about how do i do this
how do i do that how do i ask her this
what what happens when she says this and
this and this and this is down to the
most minute details and then i'm like
okay what are you going to do
when you get a date then what right and
they're like oh i hadn't got to that
part i'm like well yeah but plan to
succeed instead of planning to fail i
think is the first thing and a lot of
guys get upset with me when i say well
um
you know you you're the guy you know
you're the one who should be initiating
first of all and then second of all um
you have a plan that's that's number two
and number three you know plan for
success and then uh
plan an experience in some way i think a
lot of people like you were saying i i
agree with you probably for a different
reason when it comes to coffee and stuff
like that there's there's no
um
there's no potential for an emotional
connection and what i mean by that is uh
and i don't mean oh we're gonna fall in
love or anything like that i mean
there's got to be some sort of
excitement that emotional connection
that emotional association with that guy
can be positive or it can be negative
doesn't make any difference right
love me hate me don't forget me so it's
it you know you want a thriller and
every whatever else you know go take a
rock climbing or like you know
paragliding or something like that
associate that those highs that high
emotional association with that guy so
that that's what she
uh uh what she remembers or what is this
in in advertising it's called it's
called the emotional center of like
whatever the ad is or whatever else that
emotional center has to be when she
remembers you the first thought is oh
remember we went rock climbing remember
when we did this i don't know it went
jet skiing i don't know whatever it's a
high high intensity high you know
emotional association with that guy and
again like i said it doesn't have to be
you know parasailing it can be something
where it's like oh he made me so mad
when he said that but you still remember
that guy you still have that that
connection and that emotionality with
him so uh the only way that men can
establish that is by coming in and
saying okay here's where we're going and
here's what we're doing
and if you don't have if if you have a
problem with that then we're not going
you know we're not going to go to get
coffee we might go jet skiing instead or
we might just simply say you know what
we're going to go hiking we're going to
go do this if that's if she's not into
that then you know move on next the the
i want to get back to you i'm not a dog
i don't need to be walked you know i
don't need coffee i gotta express her
she's looking for services yeah
actual services
okay so that's one of your love
languages so what are you saying is an
ideal first date
so i say the ideal first date is a
dinner date because you can
really learn a lot about the person on
the turn date you can first off okay
i'm from croatia i'm traditional in a
certain way so i want a guy
as he said to be a man just like have a
plan
pick me up
take me to a restaurant i'm gonna see
what you order
and what i mean by that is he's not
gonna order for me but i usually like
let's say if we go on a date
i tell them okay i
like this i don't like that why don't
you order for us i want to see what you
think i would like
so based on that then i see what he
first of all what is his palette i'm a
big big foodie and that's actually one
of the
reasons why like a dinner date is so
important for me like and do you care
what type of restaurant he takes youtube
yes it doesn't it doesn't okay so it
doesn't have to be taco bell
uh well while i'm your eyes just rolled
like the back of their head right there
i actually never went to taco bell i
think
uh let's go after taco bell after that
um what type of restaurant okay so
i doesn't need to be five-star it
doesn't have to be five-star but it
cannot be a dive bar but it's just
because that's like if you are dating a
girl like me
who dresses nice has nice nails nice
hair
takes care of herself listen to her you
know meditations and this and that like
you can see that i like maybe the finer
things in life
and then based on like you need to
date in your own league i kind of feel
so if you like
certain things maybe you said rock
climbing and this and that like that's
not my style i would never go
like maybe you know that's fun for some
people but it's just not my bible you're
saying dinner dates okay where did you
want to go like what's your ideal date
okay so my boyfriend took me on a date
in a super high-end sushi restaurant in
wynwood
and it was great and it was exact it was
not too much it was not like
you know people in suits serving you but
it was nice enough and casual enough and
it had good cocktails and this and that
and like it was it was it was on point
how long have you been with your
boyfriend now almost a year okay so and
you've been married you said well i'd be
26 years 26 years and have you ever been
married any serious anything like i had
a serious relationship before but gotcha
yeah um
okay let me continue with the dinner
yeah i need to yeah i need to i need to
elaborate my hats
so when you and first off
you come to dinner date and you tell him
what would you order for us
here you can see how generous generous
he is
when it comes to
yeah it like we this is also a money
show right like it's very important what
says financial situation management yeah
we can't just like [ __ ] about money
not being important obviously it is like
it money makes the world go around yes
so when you see
what he orders if a guy shows me the
cheapest appetizer
that happened to me in the past
how dare you
like there was this dude who showed me
like the the cheapest cocktail on the
list it was like a promo and i have a
coupon i'm sure he had a coupon in his
pocket
but he showed me the cheapest thing and
i'm like i don't like that he's like oh
you're not and then you see that he's
just cheap
and it's not about dating somebody for
money even though obviously that's a
whole another topic yeah we'll get there
i'm sure
but it's like if you're showing me the
cheapest thing on the menu i see that
you are
in here already thinking to save up like
how big is the turn off is that what do
you mean how big of a turnoff oh
disgusting no unacceptable no no no
okay unacceptable how so what do you
mean like you're going to leave a date
or no i mean i have a second date i
would you'll tell all your friends
i would take whatever drink i want to
take i would hope he's going to pay for
it because
that's a first date obviously
and then i would never see him again not
not because of the pricing or like
whatever trolls are gonna jump at me
it's because like you think of me as not
an investment so you don't see me as a
management
[Music]